[Música]
segundo bloque economía en directo
américa ya está conmigo en el estudio
jóvenes de hurtado jorge bienvenido
nuevamente vamos a hablar de los
indicadores porque en eeuu cayeron las
solicitudes de las ayudas de empleo no
mejor dicho indicadores después vamos
primero con este dato de las solicitudes
ayuda empleo en eeuu así es raúl bueno
de hecho cayeron a su nivel más bajo
desde que inició la pandemia y esto
podría interpretarse como una buena
señal para el mercado laboral aunque
persiste en 'números rojos' en la
contratación el departamento de trabajo
informó que las solicitudes tuvieron su
segunda caída consecutiva de 36.000
ubicando las solicitudes de ayudas en
293 mil pese a ello hay muchas empresas
que buscan trabajadores por la pandemia
al menos tres millones de personas
quedaron en desempleo en el 2020 la tasa
de desempleo cayó a 4.8 por ciento desde
5.2 por ciento aunque buena parte de esa
disminución rowling es porque muchos de
los desempleados dejaron de buscar
trabajo y ya no se contabilizaron como
desempleados así es jorge cambiamos
ahora de información porque hay
pronósticos respecto a una posible
crisis energética global
es la demanda de petróleo podría
aumentar en medio millón por día según
aseguró la agencia internacional de
energía las consecuencias directas un
aumento adicional a los índices de
inflación y una desaceleración de la
recuperación económica post pandemia los
precios del petróleo y el gas natural
aumentaron a máximos históricos
recientemente producto de esto también
los precios de la energía aumentaron a
niveles récord a medida que la escasez
de energía afecta a asia y europa el
petróleo subió por encima de los 80
dólares del barril el más alto en tres
años esto porque los comerciantes
anticiparon que los precios del gas iban
a aumentar el consumo de otros
combustibles para generar energía esto
ya está sucediendo raúl y podría crear
una demanda de 500 mil barriles por día
durante los próximos seis meses según la
agencia los ministros de energía de la
unión europea se van a reunir el próximo
26 de septiembre 26 de octubre perdón
para abordar la crisis de precios de la
energía y gas bruselas aceptó reabrir el
debate sobre la compra conjunta de gas
que plantea en países como españa y
francia- y la idea que tener reservas
europeas similares a las que ya existen
para la gasolina y almacenarlas en
hablemos ahora de alemania jorge estamos
hablando de la mayor economía de europa
porque ya hay reportes de su crecimiento
económico los principales institutos
económicos de alemania recortaron la
previsión de crecimiento aduciendo que
la producción está siendo limitada por
los cuellos de botella de la oferta
global en las restricciones de la
pandemia el crecimiento de alemania bajó
de 3.7 por ciento al 2.4 por ciento para
este año aunque para 2022 se elevaron el
pronóstico de crecimiento a 4.8 de colon
la economía alemana raúl se basa en la
fabricación y exportación y actualmente
está siendo afectada por la escasez de
piezas y materias primas a la medida que
la cadena de suministros mundiales
batallan por cumplir con la demanda y el
alto precio de los insumos y en otro
tema jorge le pregunto qué dicen los
organismos internacionales respecto a la
inflación
bueno aseguran que la inflación global
será transitoria pero admiten que puede
prolongarse si no se acelera el acceso
global de la vacuna esto lo dijo el
fondo monetario internacional también la
vacuna fue uno de los temas principales
durante la reunión del g20 del comercio
esto dijo kristalina georgieva directora
gerente del fmi
why we should care about this porque
debería importarnos esta divergencia en
la fortuna económica entre las economías
avanzadas algunos mercados emergentes y
el resto del mundo porque mientras
persista y sobre todo si se ensancha
este riesgo de interrupciones en las
cadenas globales de suministro va a ser
mayor y por tanto la presión sobre los
precios la presión sobre la inflación
sería mayor y recordemos que también
estamos observando otros factores que
pueden afectar los precios y elevarlos
como los desastres naturales más
frecuentes que han elevado los precios
de los alimentos en tantos lugares y
griffith despont we expect ubifrance y
touring
nuevamente repito esperamos que sea
transitorio pero esto depende de la
expectativa de que aceleraremos las
vacunaciones y la recuperación donde se
está quedando atrás where it is falling
behind ahora si jorge hablemos de los
indicadores económicos como abre wall
street bueno wall street abrió en
positivo luego de que los grandes bancos
informarán resultados trimestrales
mejores de los esperados en asia los
mercados de valores del mundo en el
jueves apuntalados por un alza de las
acciones de tecnología a lo que se
sumaba en aumentos de los precios del
petróleo y del gas y en europa las
bolsas operan al alza impulsadas por el
sector inmobiliario y el sector de
tecnología y vamos a finalizar con la
cifra el día bueno la cifra el día tiene
que ver con el índice de precios al
consumidor de eeuu ese índice subió un
0.4 por ciento en septiembre llevando la
inflación anual al 5,4 por ciento una
décima más que en el mes anterior
analistas esperan una tasa anual de
inflación del 5,3 por ciento en
septiembre y el dato oficial marcó el
más alto en 13 años ya desayuno de jorge
todavía no vamos a entonces comernos una
crepe con natalia ruiz en parís le
parece vámonos vámonos
[Música]